hey baby
hey baby it's going to be for you
you keep it there's more where that came
from too
trust me that's my girl
oh damn i'm straight up talking about
some daryl dawkins right here because
this some chocolate thunder what girl
make it rain yeah oh yeah i try to make
it laugh
[Music]
all right girl mmm so pam i'm gonna get
it right in the booty right there
uh and booty swell that's that's what
you call a booty investment
it's a plan brother you really don't
need to uh uh give them that much i i
don't think they're expecting all that
it's kind of like feeding a squirrel you
know i mean they will come back to you
so oh oh oh my gosh some of this is
getting lost let's get it right where it
need to be right in there baby
oh yeah keep it classy keep it classy
oh somebody better get an umbrella cause
i can't stop making it rain it's like
it's like noah's flood up in here
two by two baby two by two
maybe you don't know that i'm the
general because it's storm in norman
that's what they be calling me
bam anyway like i said when you finish
training we get scottie mutil up in here
that you can train a box
oh lord have mercy you don't know numb
about this
make it rain
are you an idiot leon get this guy out
of here
all right nobody move there he is
they're who he is you on your feet on
your feet
what i do you're under arrest for
photocopying money oh
god damn it you know how long it took me
to cut all that out
got carpal tunnel syndrome up in this
[ __ ] callus is on the inside of my
thumbs
that's definitely real though
you